hey everyone welcome to another casual
vlog day today's video is sponsored by
natural cycles and the other week I did
a little Q&A that was requested by
everyone focusing on your questions
related to IVF and infertility and today
I wanted to do a another Q&A but focus
more on your questions related to
pregnancy and also this particular
pregnancy in baby now before we get too
far into things I of course want to get
my general disclosure that the
information you're about to see in here
is of course for education and
entertainment purposes only and should
never replace individualized medical
advice so always speak to your health
care provider about your unique case I
also want to tell you about this awesome
app called natural cycles because a lot
of you had asked me how do you conceive
like how do you get pregnant assuming of
course that you have a normal natural
cycle so I was told about this amazing
app called natural cycles that offers
both monthly or annual subscription
options and basically it can be used
either as birth control or to help you
plan a pregnancy so natural cycles works
by analyzing your basal body temperature
which is your body's lowest resting
temperature that can be indicated first
thing in the morning using a basal
thermometer so due to the rise in basal
body temperature right after ovulation
the apps algorithm can tell you what
your fertile window is and can also tell
you when you're at peak fertility so
fertile days are really shown on a color
scale with the deeper the red meaning
you're more fertile those days and green
days indicating that you are not fertile
the more data that you can give the
natural cycles app the better that the
fertility app really gets to know you so
you want to aim for at least five days
of consistent data that would be ideal
then if your temperature stays high
rather than dipping down as it would
right before you get your period the app
can tell you when the best time is to
take a pregnancy test and then when you
do get pregnant which is so exciting the
app can be switched to a follow a
pregnancy mode which will help you track
all the different fun stages of fetal
development and then after all that if
you want to avoid getting pregnant
again you can switch to the prevent mode
and the app will tell you when your
fertile days are so that will help you
avoid an unwanted pregnancy in fact it
actually is in the same effectiveness
category as the birth control pill with
a typical use effectiveness rate of 93%
and a perfect use effectiveness rate of
98% keep in mind that you must be 18
years old or older to use the app and it
does not protect against sti's but if I
had a regular cycle and I was trying to
conceive naturally or not conceived I
guess I would definitely try this out so
if you are interested check out the 20%
off link that includes a free
thermometer in the description below ok
friends now let's get to the questions
the first question I have is is this
your last pregnancy and baby okay so I'm
not sure if you can ever close a future
door when the one that you're standing
in like hasn't even closed yet but I
will say when I started the IVF process
I had 12 great embryos or blastocysts
that were frozen and I was thinking at
the time 3 that's what I had like told
my doctor like that she wrote it in my
chart desired family size was 3 babies
and I loved motherhood and that's
probably why I was like more and more
and more like I have them there's there
waiting for me so let's just have more
but I will say that this past year has
been so physically and emotionally
exhausting for me that I've kind of
reconsidered at least in how I'm feeling
right now and I have to also consider
that I kind of already have a baby like
I have my business baby and that's a big
big baby with that has a lot of needs
that I have to attend to let's just say
and my husband also is an entrepreneur
so he also has a baby so we've got our
own respective business babies we've got
two babies like human babies we have
well we will have two human babies we
have a fur baby it's a lot and I don't
want to do any
thing that I feel like I can't do 100%
and that's that's just how I feel so
right now I feel satisfied that I'm
probably done after two but who knows
like I might go through this pregnancy
and birth and I loved birth so much that
it remember like when I gave birth I was
like let's do it again let's do it again
can we do it again tomorrow so who knows
like I may change my mind after I get
through those first few terrible months
and yeah we'll reevaluate when we get
there but right now I'm thinking I'm
good okay are you having a girl or a boy
I don't know folks you guys tell me if
you have predictions leave them below
because we are not finding out and we we
didn't find out with my son either which
I know most people think I'm crazy for
because like how do you not want to know
I do want to know like I'm so curious of
course I like it kind of kills me but we
didn't find out with my son and it was
like legit one of the best surprises of
my life
I was shocked we mice up my husband I
both were 100% convinced with my with my
son that we were having a girl like we
didn't even pick a boy name so we were
like yeah it's a girl like we just I
just felt it I dreamt it I just in my
mind I kept saying she and her it wasn't
I necessarily wanted a girl it was just
that's what I thought so I guess my
instinct really sucks but regardless my
mom always says you know the the the sex
of your baby is the only surprise you're
gonna get in life other than when you're
gonna die and that's definitely true
especially for IVF like everything is so
calculated you know everything you know
like the second you implant basically
whereas you know a natural conception at
least you have a few more surprises and
excitements along the way so for me this
was the only surprise we were going to
get I also really do not like super
girly or boyish things so I mean even my
son's clothes now are pretty neutral but
I just try not to make a lot of gender
an assumption so I'm kind of trying
stick with that being here what do you
think you're having i hope i'm having a
baby not like i don't know like a dog or
an alien or dinosaur though my son would
like love it if i was having a baby
dinosaur that he would be so excited
about not a boy not a girl he wants a
dinosaur um but i don't know i think it
one has all these like funny ways to
predict baby sex like how you're
carrying or how bad your skin was or you
know how sick you were
i don't know if i really buy into any of
that if you really want to press me for
what my instinct says I would say
probably another boy but I don't know if
that's because just that's what I know
now and so when I'm saying like he I'm
always saying he or or or male pronouns
all the time so because I'm I'm always
doing that with my son so I don't know
if that's why my instinct is to call it
a he or him or whatever but I don't know
I I just also feel like a boy mom like
in my heart I just I just feel like that
is Who I am and I will be thrilled with
another boy I love being a boy mom I
love my son he's he is so funny and fun
and as a high-energy person I think we
just really drive well together it's I
can't wait to see him grow up so I would
be thrilled to have two little boys as
brothers also so excited to have a
little daughter as well because I mean
who doesn't want to dress up a little
daughter though I will say I'm legit
terrified of having a daughter mainly
because of the teenage years and what I
probably put my mother through so yeah
it comes with a lot more anxiety but
some more cute clothing options for sure
if it is a girl so I'm so excited for
either option let's just have a healthy
happy baby okay do you have names picked
out I have names picked out
it hasn't hasn't heard them yet but
thank you guys all for sending your your
name suggestions especially the boy
names cuz you know they are so much
harder for me I feel good about my girl
name choice I just have to hope that my
husband also feels good about it though
we don't have the best track record for
agreeing on names in fact we didn't have
a boy name that we agreed upon until
well after I gave birth I literally just
told my husband that I was writing his
name down on the birth certificate
because hey I just pushed him out of my
body so I think women get a little bit
more wiggle room a few more votes on the
names in my opinion but I don't know
argue with me if you want the comments
on that so yeah please keep the keep the
name suggestions coming like I said I
like unusual names but not to like
hipster where it's like you know we see
these like lists of like unusual names
and those are too common for me now to
unusual comment I want like all names
that are kind of I'm gonna bring back or
kind of made-up names because they're
places or there there were other things
or objects or whatever that's that's
what my thinking is going without it
getting like too too weird but give me
your ideas I love them next question do
you have any cravings or food aversions
I am like so super boring but I don't
have any like crazy cravings like I have
not sent my husband out to get
McDonald's in the middle of the night
and also like a frosty for like dipping
the fries and the in the frosty none of
that stuff like and I didn't with my son
either
I will say that aversions yes they were
probably I don't know if they were worse
with my son I remember not being able to
eat any chicken at all with my son or
fish just a smell of fish the whole
pregnancy turned me off and it like took
months before I could eat a chicken
breast again after giving birth I will
say like raw vegetables in the first
trimester were ate hard no for me I
remember like eating a salad or ordering
a Greek salad at like like ten weeks
pregnant or something and then just like
eating the feta cheese off the top and I
was like mmm that was a waste of money I
could have just had a block of cheese so
now that I am further along and I'm kind
of like past that I'm feeling good
I can eat vegetables again and it's so
exciting I guess if there's anything I'm
craving it's like really
you see water-rich things so like
vegetables and fruit like acidic fruits
like pineapple well when I was in
Florida I eat a ton of watermelon and
that was so exciting I eat a lot of
clementines so let a lot of those kind
of like tangy acidic foods are really
feeling good for me right now but I I
love hearing about people's cravings so
leafy comments below if if there was
something funny and weird that you were
craving I can't really think of anything
for myself I wish I did I wish I did
because it's just something fun to to
remember as part of your pregnancy but
nope I'm boring I just like I love
vegetables and fruit and other dietician
tea things so who knows okay do you have
any other ideas for morning sickness so
great question lots of ginger choose
anything kind of tangy like I said
acidic things tend to help and lemon
ginger tea was a lifesaver for me I
drank a lot of that and I just brewed it
myself so I just literally just like
steeped ginger in water and then added
lots of lemon juice and I love that and
if you can even add a little honey if
that's too acidic for you but I just
like the UH tang and so the other thing
I would say is just like kind of small
energy dense meals and snacks so I
really try to focus on not be like big
volumous meals so like where I might
have a salad normally the salad would
just be like too much for me I couldn't
like get through it so I really focused
on adding more fats to my meals just to
add more calories in there so like not
better like cooking with a little bit
more fat avocado sprinkling hemp parts
or chia seeds or or or flax on basically
everything these little nutritional
boosters do add up throughout the day
without making you feel overly full or
uncomfortable as for carbs I had no
guilt about eating like mainly carbs in
the first trimester I just tried
whenever possible to choose kind of like
a slow digesting carb carb that had a
little bit of protein in it or paired
with some
protein so for example like whole-grain
bread with maybe some fat or protein
some like nut butter or some avocado or
like the avocado toast that I showed you
in my video which I'll link to below I
also did like oatmeal with lots of hemp
arts or nut butter swirled in loved that
I had like oatmeal for breakfast and
lunch and dinner somedays no no guilt no
shame what else Oh
bean based pasta is amazing I use it a
lot of my recipes but and I love it for
my kid as well because you know picky
toddlers and morning sick
pregnant ladies are not that different
when it comes to their diet so bean
based pasta is great because at least if
like I just felt so sick that all I
could it was like plain dry what I mean
cooked but like no sauce pasta at least
I was getting a little bit more protein
in that so that was another great option
but bottom line I would say smaller
energy dense meals and ideally ones
without any kind of strong scent or odor
like fishy things were a hard pass for
me next question is it as scary as it
seems from the outside I'm not really
sure if that question was referring to
pregnancy in general or like in
fertility and IVF but let's keep it a
pregnancy and say I mean sure like there
are scary aspects of of pregnancy
especially in that first trimester I
can't tell you how nerve-wracking every
day is like as somebody who's gone
through a lot of infertility and gone
through a lot to actually get here to
get pregnant to get that positive
pregnancy test
yeah like every day especially in that
first trimester I would go to the
washroom and check for blood and any
little feeling like any little cramp I
would feel I would in my mind think the
worst that I was having a miscarriage
and I'd like kind of go through this
grieving process even before I knew what
was going on
so the first trimester is really scary
but I've
I'm through it and that doesn't mean
that I'm completely in the clear you're
never in the clear you're always gonna
worry but I will say I feel a lot more
calm now having
past that real kind of danger zone as
for you know the later stages of
pregnancy like like actual labor I will
say in my first pregnancy I was
terrified of labor like most women I
mean we're all scared of the pain and
the unexpected and and things can go
wrong there's just it's it's scary but
haven't gone through it I feel a lot
more calm about the entire experience
Bost both like labor delivery and
postpartum and what to expect but I will
say that the thing I was most scared of
in my first pregnancy was pushing in
labor I was just so scared I'm gonna
talk about how painful it is the Ring of
Fire and just like I was scared of
tearing my vagina like it was scary
stuff but I will say that pushing that
hour I was pushing was literally the
best hour of my life it was so exciting
I had a room full of people cheering me
on uh I felt like a rock star I felt
like I was the you know I was I was like
an athlete and and the whole stadium was
just like go Abbi go you're doing
amazing like it was so invigorating and
I know there's a lot of like endorphins
that are also happening to help you deal
with that kind of pain and deal with
that the the adrenaline of trying to
push that baby out it's a lot of
physical effort but I will say it was so
incredible do not be scared of labor I
mean the epidural helped that's that's
for sure I'm not sure I'd be so
enthusiastic about the pushing phase had
I not had an epidural but that's what
worked for me and I loved it and I am
actually genuinely excited to do it
again alright next question what
prenatal vitamin do you recommend I mean
there's lots of great brands out there
so choose something that's within budget
for you but I do always recommend
something with methyl folate or
methylated folate rather than just
simple Foley which coz methylated fully
is the active form of folate and so I
like rituals prenatal vitamin that
methyl Foley in it and also mega foods
baby and me too that's what I'm using
right now but yeah lots of great brands
out there choose a brand that works for
your budget but also ideally that has
the methylfolate when did you start
taking your prenatal vitamin so I guess
for me I just like didn't really ever
stop you know I remember and I've said
this many times that my my university
professor in nutrition school said you
know if you're a childbearing age you
should be taking a prenatal vitamin
because mistakes can happen and it's
really important to be getting that
extra folate in for those early weeks of
pregnancy often before women even know
that they're pregnant so I was taking it
I know I think it probably started
before I was like married and thinking
about having kids and then I took it all
throughout IVF to get through pregnancy
took through breastfeeding because it's
also can really help with breastfeeding
your your nutritional needs are a lot a
lot higher in breast and breast feeding
than when you're not breastfeeding so
that was important and then I went
through your breast feeding right back
into IVF and preparing for pregnancy and
then into pregnancy so I'm probably just
gonna stay on it for for for I don't
know maybe forever
I don't know depends I know it's a
little bit more expensive than a normal
multivitamin but you never know like
maybe a miracle accident will happen and
I'd rather be safe than sorry
okay have you gained more weight in this
pregnancy than you did in your first I
don't know probably I'm going to go see
the doctor's day and he'll weigh me and
I really don't weigh myself but I also
have have been on a lot more drugs and
hormones than I was in my first
pregnancy including prednisone which is
not it was not very kind to me that's
for sure I'm also older like I'm
two-and-a-half years older and just like
more tired and less fit than I was
having like kind of just got married and
was like young and fresh and energetic
and uh those were the days but yeah I
actually didn't
that much weight in my first pregnancy I
think I only gained like 18 to 20 pounds
which is less than the recommended and I
was like actively trying to gain weight
by the end they're like we're really
trying to catch up but my son was seven
seven which is a perfectly average
weight so I feel like your body is just
gonna do what its gonna do and and you
know you don't need to force feed
yourself but just listen to your body
when it comes to your nutritional needs
and your hunger needs which which will
increase especially with breastfeeding I
was starving like legit starving we'll
do a whole other video on breast feeding
if your inch do not leave me comments
below and I will tell you everything I
know about pumping and breastfeeding but
but yeah I just truly believe that if
you're listening to your body and and
you're eating in in response to those
hunger cues and those enhanced hunger
cues that your body will gain the weight
that it needs to gain okay how do you
feel about your weight gain and your
changing body during pregnancy this is a
really great question and you know
something that I think a lot people
don't talk about because it's kind of
taboo especially in the infertility
world where you know you've worked so
hard to get pregnant how can anything
else matter how could you dare even have
a negative thought about something as
trivial as your weight gain but I'll be
honest like it's it's never it's always
a little unnerving when your clothes
don't fit even if obviously in pregnancy
you're meant to gain weight and I know I
talk all the time about body positivity
but I will say body positivity is not
necessarily looking your body every
single day and thinking that it is like
Rockstar super sexy all the time to me
it's really about respecting your body
and honoring your body's needs which is
something of course I will continue to
do and have been continuing to do
despite the fact that like hey sometimes
I just feel kind of bloated and and and
bigger like there's a long period in
pregnancy where you don't really look
super pregnant you just look bigger your
clothes don't fit but you don't have
that cute
the ball bub that you can show off you
just feel a look not like yourself and
that can be kind of uncomfortable I've
also found that in my second pregnancy
this is very common a lot of my friends
say this but I showed showed a lot
faster and a lot bigger than I did in my
first pregnancy and like everyone has
mentioned that to me like about me
so side note folks never comment on a
woman's body period but even in
pregnancy pregnancy does not give you
the right to comment on or touch a
woman's body without asking you know I'm
joining to do a whole video on this cuz
I I could go off on this so leave me a
comment below if you want to see any
rant on all the things you should never
say or do to a pregnant woman when it
comes to her body I I will go off but
anyways
sometimes hearing these remarks even
though I consider myself a pretty
confident person and I feel quite
comfortable in my own skin and in my own
body even when it is changing if someone
is really hurt to hear that from people
but anytime that I have a negative
thought if I look in the mirror I just
say to myself wow how Abby think about
how amazing your body is for doing
everything that it's doing right now and
I also tell myself you know my body is
so smart it will find its healthy happy
place again when it's ready and
sometimes I also then ask myself if I if
I am having these negative thoughts how
terrible would it be if my body just
stayed this size and shape forever and
when I actually ask myself that question
rationally I realize not terrible at all
like I'm still healthy I'm still happy
that is all that ultimately matters to
me so what like having bigger love
handles is not going to define who I am
all of this is just another phase and
I'm gonna try to take this one step at a
time so on that note everybody I hope
you enjoyed this little Q&A if you have
other questions for me whether it's
really related to pregnancy
we could do a video on breastfeeding and
pumping if you're interested because I
have lots to say about that my friends I
had quite the struggle in my first
pregnancy I did a video on that here but
yeah leave me a comment below I would
love to hear from you if you like these
kinds of easy Q&A style videos also
don't forget to check out my merch line
I'm leaving a link below the sweaters
are back in stock so I'm really excited
to share that with you guys so don't
forget about that also big thank you to
natural cycles for sponsoring this video
if you liked it give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]